too
tni
今日のプログラムは1時に始まりました
この会場に来る前
今日の昼ごはん皆さんは何を召し上がられましたか
その中に鹿児島の食材が入っていたでしょうか
鹿児島は本当に食が豊かな土地です
農業や水産畜産業
そして食品や飲料の加工製造
物を売る販売運ぶ運輸そしてもちろん飲食業や宿泊業
様々な食に関わる仕事が存在します
私は鹿児島の食の魅力を伝える仕事をしています
鹿児島の食をどこかの誰かに食べてもらいたいということを日々考えています
誰かの食卓の上に鹿児島の食が載っている
そんな光景をいつもイメージしています
職の仕事ですが何かものを作り出しているわけではありません
食と人コミュニケーションで結ぶその計画を立てるのが私の役割
仕事上の最も密接なパートナーはデザイナーです
この仕事をするようになったきっかけは鹿児島に引っ越してきた頃
義理の母との会話にありました
母は
鹿児島で生まれ育った生粋の鹿児島の人で一生を得ました
とても料理の上手な人で行くたびにたくさんご馳走を作ってもてなしてくれたんです
母の家に行くとさあさあこれを食べなさいあれを食べなさい
これは鹿児島の特産なのよいろんな料理を用意してくれます
私はそれをいただいて本当に美味しいですねおかあさん
これも鹿児島の特産何ですか知りませんでした
すると母は言ったものです
そうなの鹿児島はね美味しいものがたくさんあるんだけどあんまり知られてないの宣伝
が下手なの
これと同じような会話は母以外の人とも色んな場面でいろんな方とを行ったことがあり
ます
誇りを持っているのにわかってもらえないもどかしさ
そんなものが伝わってきました
そこで私は
その時に食と人情報で結ぶ
美味しさのデザイン
それをテーマにしようと決めました
みなさんのお宅冷蔵庫の中に賞味期限切れの職人があった時に食べますか
食べませんか
どうされますか
私はお会いした方によくこの質問するんです
男性は食べられないと判断するかパートナーの方に尋ねるという方が多いです
女性はクンクンと匂いを嗅いだりじっと眺めたりして食べられるかどうか判断する人が
多いようですが笑っていらっしゃるということはそういうことでしょうか
これおそらく性別というよりは自分で食を作るしとか牛とかどうかということに拘っ
てるんだと思います
この場合の賞味期限
食に関する一つの情報です
賞味期限を見て食べる食べないを判断する考える
まず今の体にな害をなすものは食べたくない
そういうことを判断するための情報です
なまこ
とても奇妙な形をしていますがこれを一番最初に食べた人は誰なんでしょ
フグもキモ以外は食べて大丈夫ということがわかるまで何人の人が命を落としたこと
でしょうか
そして今シーズンですね美味しい季節のきのこ
食べて良いきのこそして毒キノコもあります
どうやって区分してきたのでしょう
人類が積み上げてきた食べて良いものと悪いもの
そういう情報もあります
時を遡ることは江戸時代
今と同じようにグルメ情報誌がありました
食の楽しみを追求するための情報です
お相撲の番付と同じように料理やがランキングされています
江戸の子たちもあの店は今回はランクだったなぁなんてへ
話で盛り上がっていたにちがいありません
お父さんやお母さん
子供の事を一番に考えている人が作る食は安心の食です
作ったのは誰か
これも一つの情報です
鹿児島でも最近海外からの観光客の方が増えてきました
イスラム教徒の方ムスリムの人たちは戒律によって食べても良いものやその調理法が
決まっています
そのルールに従った職を貼るといい
これらのマークがついています
これも食に関する一つの情報です
結局私たちが何かを食べるとき
意識的にも無意識的にも必ず情報を活用しています
逆に言うと情報がない食は食べられない
もしくは食べたくはならないということになります
情報によって食べたいという救命地を作り出していきたいと思った私は
どうやってアプローチしようと
いろんな本を読みましたいろんなことを調べてみました
するとこんなことがわかったんです
心理学や社会学情報学
それ以外にも沢山の学問の分野が美味しいということに関わっているということが
分かりました
食べるとか美味しいと思う気持ちはとても日常的なことなのに案外美味しいは複雑なん
です
科学的にアプローチをしようとすると
大変な分野に足を突っ込んでしまったなとたくさんの専門誌を前に嘆いたこともあり
ます
それでもどうにかおいしさをデザインしていきたいと思って私は食べる前と食べるとき
この2つに分けて考えることを試みました
食べる時食べるときは口の中に直接ものを入れますから
雨宮さん御縁3苦み甘み
これらの5つの味
味わうことができます
そしてその味覚以外にもおいしそうな盛り付けは資格
肉が焼ける音は聴覚
ナイフに伝わる肉の柔らかさこれは触覚
そしてワインの香りは嗅覚になります
食べるときはいろんな感覚を駆使して情報を得ています
じゃあ一歩を食べる前はどうなんでしょう
食べる前というのはそのものを食品を食べるかどうかを決める時です
例えば先ほどの賞味期限切れの食品を食べるかどうか
スーパーに行ってどの商品を買うかどうか
レストランでどのメニューを頼むかどうかです
スーパーやレストラン二度目からは心配いりません
一回食べているからわかります
でも初めての時どうやってその食品を買うんでしょう
選ぶんでしょう
食べる前ですから
先ほどの5つの味使用することができません
味覚は使いません
資格
パッケージ見た情報情報誌に載っていたおいしそうな写真
資格は使えます
聴覚有事にから聞いたあの店おいしいよという情報
そしてお店の人から聞く調理方法
聴覚も使っています
触覚
食べる前に食品を直接触って確認できる
そういうケースはほとんどないはずです
そして嗅覚
お店の前を誰だよおいしそうな匂いにつられたことありますよね
嗅覚も使えます
視覚聴覚嗅覚
この3つの感覚を使って私たちを食べる前の情報を得ています
食べる前に情報を受信できる感覚はとても限られているんです
でも限られているからでしょうかこれらの感覚
実はした以上に味の評価に影響を端与えているということがわかっています
2つ
お話しします
まず一つ目はこの嗅覚のお話です
風邪をひいて鼻が詰まった時に何かを食べても味がしなかった
美味しくなかったという経験ありませんか
それは下は匂いとセットで味を感じているところが多いんです
匂いの方が味を館口でいるところが多いんです
逆に言えばしただけでは味は感じにくいということになります
そしてもう一つ
日本集を利き酒するとき
彼らは口の中に日本症克服んだ後
空気を混ぜるようにすするようにします
そして香りを立てています
なぜでしょうか
香りのほうが
記憶が鮮明だからです
下の記憶よりも香りの記憶能が鮮明だから過去に飲んだ日本酒の経験を探しに行ってる
んです
こんな風に臭いがあるから味がわかる
香りがあるから記憶できるこれが嗅覚の力です
今度は資格の話です感覚10位という言葉があるんです
これはアメリカの心理学者が発表した言葉である調査の結果
発表されたものです
簡単にご紹介します
8 p
2つのブランデー同じグラスに入れました
そして多くの方に飲んで頂きます
どちらが美味しいですかと尋ねると
映画おいしいという人が多かったんです
今度はその a と b のグラスの横に
それぞれのボトルをきました
グロスの中は同じ8 b それぞれのブランデーのままです
また同じように多くの人に飲んでもらいどちらが美味しいか尋ねたんです
すると今度はビートが美味しいという人が多かったんです
これは商品の評価つまり味の評価ブラン税の味の強化に
ボトルパッケージデザインが影響を与えている
う
資格データ情報がしたの情報に影響を与えているという意味で感覚10位と言われてい
ます
この資格について一つエピソードを話します
この本は私が小学生の時人生で初めて
ジャケ買いをした時の商品です
本屋さんの中の児童書のコーナー
小学生向けな感じの優しい可愛らしい
本がたくさん並ぶ中
ちょっと悪人顔に惹かれて買いました
少年たちと泥棒の話なんですけども中にたくさんおいしそうな料理が出てきて本当に
食べたいなぁと思いながらワクワクしながら読んだことをよく覚えています
このようにレコードや cd のジャケット
例えば本や雑誌の表紙
そういうものを好ましいと思って物を買うの
鮭がいています
このジャケット例えば皆さんがスーパーに行かれた時
何に当たるかというとパッケージデザインにあたります
そのパッケージデザインが商品の売れ行きとどんな風に関係するのか
少しご紹介したいと思います
商品の中身味と外側のパッケージ二つの観点からご説明しますね
このグラフは商品を販売してからの期間がよく軸にとってあります
縦月は売れ行きです上に伸びれば伸びるほど売れているということになります
ええわ商品の中身もパッケージもとても良いというパターンです
パッケージに惹かれてどんどん買っていただけます買うと満足します美味しいから
そしてもう一度かいます場合によってはあれはすっごくおいしいを口コミも発生します
それが a のパターンです
b は途中で失速してますよね
b は外側のパッケージはいいけれど商品の中身に課題があるケースです
パッケージに載っている情報を判断して釣られて多くの人が買ってくれます
ですが食べると不満が残ります二度と買うことはありません
そして友人にいますあれは見た目ほど美味しくないよ
c は少しずつ売れていきます
商品の中身はいいけれども
パッケージに課題があるケースです
パッケージの情報が不足しているのであまり売れません
気付いてもらえません
でもたまに買ってくれる人がいるんです
そうするとその買ってクレスタ人たちは商品の中身がいいので大変満足します次も買い
ます
リピーターになりますそして知り合いにいます
あれって結構美味しいのよ
このシーンのパターンはパッケージのデザイン
そこからハする情報が変わっていればええと同じように売れていた可能性があるという
ことになります
皆さんが関わっていらっしゃる食品そして商品やサービスは本来あるべきう冷気を示し
ているでしょうか
正当な評価を受けていますかお客様に届いていますか
売れ行きがいいといいことがたくさんあります
もちろん売上上がるしまとめて作れるからコストも下がって利益が出やすくなります
そして何より作り手が元気になるんです
売れ行きが悪いというのは
お客様に無視されているということです
無視されるというのはつらいものです寂しいものです
せっかく商品の形で提案したのに何も反応が返ってこないということです
売れ行きというのは反応の一つ
ブレーキがいいと意欲が湧いてきますアイディアもたくさん出てきます
受信後湧いてきます会社や地域が自立した形容することが可能になります
会社4地域が本当に元気になっていくんです
かっこいいデザインがいいよとかオシャレなデザインにしましょうというつもりは全く
ありません
中身を誇張して伝えて下さいっていうのはもってのほかですそうではなくてその商品の
存在と
中に含まれている本当の価値をきちんと伝えていただきたいんです
そしてお客様に買っていただきましょう喜んでいただきましょう
そして
作り手の方にも喜んでいただきたいと強く願っています
デザインにはいろんな力があるんですけどまず言えるのは
情報整理して伝える力があるということです
強力なパートナーです
デザインは地域の宝物それも地域にもれた宝物に光を当てることができます
どうか作ることに加えて伝えること
そうです伝えることに力を注いでください
なぜなら
食べるという行為も美味しいと思う気持ちもすべては情報を伝えることからのみ
始まるからです
地域の人が作り出す地域の食が
今よりももっと愛されますように
ありがとうございました